again live in full effect for
2024 oops started the music too soon but
it is what it is ladies and
gentlemen welcome
back
2024 and your favorite
[Music]
podcast
W
[Music]
yeah
g
[Music]
w welcome back to riffin with Griffin my
friends we are back all new riffin with
Griffin you know got a lot going on but
like I got the new Monday segment for
patreon and all those people and then
once again it's always Griffin Griffin
on Wednesdays today there's so much much
Epstein list Cat Williams interview
Golden Gloves um a couple of reviews of
some stuff I really like but as always
here we are with
[Music]
real you know the voice didn't start off
good today but you know it is what it is
what's up y'all welcome back to riffin
with Griffin we are live we are live
once again again and I appreciate
everybody being here as always I know I
I didn't do it last week you know I got
a lot going on in my life right now uh
you know baby on the way but as always
thank you for subscribing that helps a
lot so please
subscribe share do all that stuff uh hit
the notifications so you know when I'm
going live I'm going live on Wednesdays
um I'll tell you everything and then you
know on Twitch if you're twitch people
you know I love twitch I'm on Twitch all
the time
doing my uh I'm I'm going be on Twitch
actually doing the the the Monday
segments too so if you want to watch
that live if you're a twitch subscriber
you can watch the whole thing but if you
want to catch a little bit of it you can
watch five minutes for free when you go
to Twitch because it's subscriber only
then it's going to patreon and stuff
like that that's just me getting buck
wild and raw with all kind whatever's
happening in the moment you know
sometimes there's always some crazy
stuff and as always I finally promise
you every Monday patreon content so all
you people that want to be a part of the
patreon Now's the Time you know and I
appreciate all the people that have been
doing it just just to support me and I
appreciate that so and here we are
everybody back again riffin with
Griffin um yeah so thank you as always
you know what I mean you guys are great
uh you know I love the the my my fans
that come up to me at airports at comedy
clubs you know you bought tickets from
me last year in 2023 all the people that
supported we're going to keep doing it
this year so I mean as you know I mean
the biggest news right now is that you
know Rachel we are like in our eighth
month now so it's like literally any
time now this lady she could be bursting
you know ready to burst this baby out so
it has been an incredible journey it
really has you know nine like almost
nine months of like you know all the
things the preparing the doctor's
appointments uh you know dealing with
like um making her comfortable the the
emotions of it uh I am still so nervous
I am nervous and anxious and scared you
know it's like you know I've lived a
long time already and now it's like I
have to live uh you know for someone
else you know what I mean like to make
sure that this kid has a happy healthy
life and uh you know make sure my wife
is is happy and it's just like it can be
overwhelming to think about it but
yeah man it is what it is so it's been
you know like I say it's it's quite a
journey that we've been going on so now
we're going into we're going to the
doctor every week so all the people that
know about that have had kids you know
how that it goes right now so right now
we're at the every week and you know we
go in and like they we did an ultrasound
last week and it was so it was just
incredible you know there just great
picture of the you know he has like we
see like two fingers like he's given
like the peace sign you know what I mean
uh it's crazy just little
kid so you know we had the ultrasound
then then the next last week a couple
days ago we went and they you know we
heard the heartbeat again the baby's
strong it's probably going to be a big
ass baby you know Rachel's almost 6 foot
I'm 6'3 you know her dad's almost seven
foot so you know we going we having a
big ass baby um you know I'm thinking 10
lbs I feel like the baby's going to be
like you know 10 pounds we got to do
like a over under what do you think my
baby's going to be right now like like
about three weeks ago when we did this
other ultrasound they measured and they
were like okay the baby's uh seven seven
pounds and something you know they
figured and I was like damn and that's
like we still got time to go and the
baby grows like I don't know half a
pound every week or something I don't
even know how it all works or it's crazy
but I think it's going to be a big ass
baby but you know that's what's been
going on with in in and then the the
thing too is in my workout Journey uh
I've been like really I've been at it
man and oh I love
it I love working out
I love the the weightlifting part of it
and so you know if you follow me on
Instagram you could check my weight loss
Journey that's going on there uh it's
really you know I realize that there's
like and I and someone sent me this
message too on Instagram I wish I have a
person's name so I can give them full
credit but you know weight loss for me
now is like you know it's three three
aspects of it right now okay so I'm
doing the cardio for my heart health cuz
that's what cardio is for your heart
health you know so I can like also so I
can run
you know so like I've been doing this uh
when I do my warmup before I do like the
main exercises with my trainer is you
know I'll be on the I'll go on the
treadmill for like 15 minutes you know
just a a walk with an incline you know
but the last six minutes I'll put the
treadmill on like 4.5 and then I'll run
for a minute and then walk for a minute
run for a minute walk for a minute and
you know I'm I'm getting there now I can
really do the whole full minute run I
know that doesn't seem like a lot but
like if your kid is running towards
traffic I want to be able to like I got
to skidadle and go get this kid right so
I'm just trying to take care of myself
for all those reasons too and it also
feels good so you got the cardio for
your heart health so you can like you
know moving and grooving and the blood
flow helps with your brain second aspect
is I want to be stronger so that's what
the weightlifting the weightlifting is
about my strength you know so I'm like I
love to actually love the weightlifting
and I feel stronger too I love like you
know I'm around the house lifting [__]
and I'm like oh this feels good because
you got to lift this baby and shout out
to my trainer Willis he's always like
you're going to have to get on the
ground and get pick up this baby you're
going to have to hold so he's doing he
does a lot of exercises where I'm
lifting and squatting and and putting my
body weight on the ground and getting up
oh man the worst exercise is this thing
called Walking push-ups I hate it just
walking push-ups you have to like I have
to like go down to the ground in a
push-up position and then get myself
back up without using my like putting my
hands on my knees or anything like that
and and I have to do that 12 times now
you might think that that sounds easy
but if you're if you're heavy like me
you know if you're like d I'm 300 lb
right now it's crazy don't even seem
like it you know but
um yeah it's hard but it's like that's
what you have to do get on the ground
with the kid and get back up again so
but I feel myself slendering down I can
see it in my face you know my shoulders
are filling out a little bit and so you
know this is just the start of the
weight loss Journey
so uh you know we'll see where that's
going right now but that's been that's
been pretty good man the weight loss
part of it has just been the you know
the working out weight so that's the
three aspects of it oh and the third
aspect I forgot is your weight is about
what you eat so and that's the hardest
part if we're being honest you know like
working out for like you know 20 minutes
is like ultimately that's
nothing the food you intake you know
three four times a day every single day
to survive and trying to manage what
that is that's the hard part for all of
us but if you break it down and think
about those three things it doesn't have
to be this daunting overwhelming thing
about like oh my God I want to look good
naked and my physique isn't changing
it's about feeling good you know cardio
for your heart for your mental brain
flows so you know you don't have brain
fog and you know you're just you're
feeling good about yourself the
strengthening for your weight you know
weight lifting so your body is stronger
and that helps with weight loss and then
the food you take so that's
definitely uh the thing man you know so
we'll see how it goes but right now it's
going pretty good you know so I've been
off um I've been off uh no ads today you
know I got I don't even know if I'm
might have ads for this year we have to
see you know I mean shout out to all
things comedy get to work give me some
ads um
but um you know it's been uh it's been a
crazy it was a crazy 2023 you know cuz
you know you know my wife has been
pregnant the whole time but a lot of
stuff has been happening and and oh
again I want to say again remember every
Monday now Mondays I will be
doing uh at Monday mornings I'm try to
do it every at 10 a.m. every Monday live
on Twitch and then that video will go
for my patreon so if you want to be a
twitch subscriber you watch it live
there or later if you're a YouTube
member I don't know how many YouTube
members I have I got to check but mostly
for patreon YouTube members and twitch
subscribers that video will go up and I
I I'll do it live on Twitch and
sometimes I'll do a little teaser on
Instagram live too we'll see but I'm
going to be doing the extra content
promise you that so if you go if you go
there there you
go so anyways um you know what oh you
know what let's go to our comments let's
go to our comments like we'd like to do
we still doing our comment
section um for the you know every day
all right so uh so somebody once again
another comment about the Lee Brothers
podcast you know this could have been
the greatest Trio podcast of all time
Jack b616 yeah yeah
probably but you know people it is what
it
is uh
Fernando Banu
benas P
whatever as a mover he said because this
is about I remember there was this movie
company movie company disaster of Way
episodes way ago I don't even remember
what it was but he said the customers
also should know the danger ERS of
requesting such a hard demand the couch
would be difficult to take up there
because of the angle of the stairs see
everybody has know what this that common
is about perspective So you you're Mo
you're paying people to help you move
they are messing up your stuff and then
here's a mover being like hey man this
is actually a hard job and you know you
got to be aware of stuff so you know
just always think there's uh another you
know there's another perspective to
everything uh let's see
uh let's see Cho sir about time you show
up where you been I've been like busy
being trying to be a a future dad per
you know fixing up this baby room is so
much man so somebody said man main gamer
gamer with two hours three days ago
Griffin let me work for you I'll post
your Clips daily everywhere okay well
hit me up
dude um let's see
here um I don't know what this that's
stupid okay so here we go Nate Sapa 8338
Eric would love to hear your take on Cat
Williams vers Steve and Cedric drama
going on right now he was on the club sh
Shay wondering if you got a chance to
see it all right so let's just get into
[Laughter]
it you know so that's just where that's
where we're at now y'all that's where
we're at
um yeah man this uh uh Cat
Williams
um yeah this this Cat Williams Club sh
Shay thing has been like uh you know
it's taking over the internet you know a
lot of people are talking about it a lot
of people are making videos about it I'm
doing it right now right but it just
really is a testament to the type of
Personality that Cat Williams is the
dude is really just one of the things
about him he's a fantastic orator okay
okay he's got that thing that when he
speaks you want to listen to him whether
you agree with him or not he got that
thing you know what I'm talking about he
you know he could have been like there's
people in history that have a it Factor
you know they become they become like
comedians they become dictators they
become um movie stars or they become
cult leaders they become you know it's
like this crazy career
that certain people have and whether you
love him or hate him cat got that thing
man he got this thing about it he could
have been he could have been like a a a
a mega church leader you know what I
mean
congregation this is your pastor Pastor
Williams you know he could have had that
thing that everybody would have been
like you know and it's like and there's
been people in history who you like on
different sides of the spectrum of what
you think is good and evil or what you
think has been moral or immoral but they
all have that thing someone like farahan
got that thing you know he he could talk
he makes you be like oh okay but then
he'll say something off-putting and
you'll be like oh man what but you lost
in the sauce you know Hitler I mean
think about Hitler for him to like
inspire people the way he did the dude
could have been a if he was alive today
he could have been a great movie star if
he had decided not to do what he did
maybe he would have been a great man who
knows right but he he chose a evil path
right um Martin Luther King he had that
thing he could speak the way he spoke
the way he used words uh to to paint
pictures in your head you know he was
just great at that you know he was a
powerful leader because of the way he
spoke you know but then you have people
like Charles Manson Who convinced people
to be crazy like he convinced people
that he was like God or something and
and there are people that you know you
know you have because you know what I
mean like there are people that believe
these cult leaders and they've done
crazy things but when you hear them they
they had some sort of Charisma you know
anyways I'm getting off track the point
is Cat Williams got that
thing now here's how I feel about some
of the stuff in the Cat Williams uh
thing first of all a lot of this is 20
years old a lot of this is ongoing a lot
of this is like you know cat's
perspective so like I'm going to pick a
a part one thing like the Ricky Smiley
part of this okay so Ricky Smiley was
also in Friday After Next the thing that
really blew cat up especially in the
black community cat became a superstar
he played Money Mike in Friday after
next and he was this like hilarious pimp
character that he put a lot of you know
he put a lot of his own artistic
creativity in it and that's from Ice
Cube's own mouth it was supposed to be a
small role Ice Cube also made a a video
about it and he came out and he talked
about it right so
um you know the
um so cat put himself in it in into it
okay so so here's what I'm saying about
there's different perspectiv this is
cat's truth cat has heard these people
talk about uh what happened and he felt
slided he felt like hey you're not
telling the story correct so he gave his
version of the story but in any in any
situation in any conflict you got to
listen to both sides and someplace in
the middle is the truth here's what I
think would
happen and this is even what from Ice
Cube and uh from Ice Cube too the the
producer of the movie so Ricky Smiley
goes into audition for this part of
Money Mike they they go all right you
know what this guy's big right now you
know what you did okay we're going to
give you the part and he
tells they tell Ricky Smiley you know
what you got the park bro this is your
part then they're still auditioning
people and Cat Williams comes in and
blows them away and just it would be a
crime to not give him this part like he
was so good at this part they were like
oh man all right hey Ricky um here's
another role you you you're not going to
be that role we're giving you this role
instead uh this guy is just too good and
then they gave the role to Cat Williams
and then cat's like he made it better
right and he he he wrote lines and they
were like yo this guy's still good we
got to add this character to the movie
more okay now cat to your Ricky Smiley
and how are you going to retell this
story how are you going to tell people
cuz are you going to tell people yeah
man I auditioned for this part and then
there was this other dude came in and he
was way better than me and they gave the
part to him you not telling the story
like that you're not going to retell the
story like that you might retell the
story like yeah you know uh you know
yeah being a part of uh that movie was
great you know they actually like
switched the roles uh you know I ended
up being this other character and Cat
ended up being that character like
you're not going to say this dude I mean
you should probably I mean I don't think
there's any shame in being like yeah
when you see the end product 20 years
later you should be able to look at it
and be like yeah that man I but I get
the competitive nature of being a comic
you're competitive right but like it's
years later just come out and be like
yeah dude I I almost had the part and
then cat came in and just took it CU he
was so good ain't no shame in that but
if you telling the story in a way that
makes it seem like oh yeah they you know
but I get why he would do it like that
so if you're cat of course you're gonna
be like yo what that's lies you know and
so he has his perspective and I think
that there's some truth in the middle of
all of it so
you know I think that that's kind of
what happened that's just my perspective
about uh you know what happened in that
particular sit situation you know what
I'm saying uh but you know I do think
also
cat he yeah like somebody said in the
chat he embellishes things and he you
know I just I just want to remind people
that this is his perspective now when it
comes to Steve Harvey and and and the
Kings of Comedy and all that stuff this
is not new stuff they've been talking
about their beef for years now it's not
just Cat Williams bringing up the fact
that there was some tension between
Bernie Mack and and uh Steve Harvey and
and and and Cedric about who should go
first who should go last who you know
you know you're putting out this thing
called the Kings of Comedy meaning like
you're saying you guys are the best and
when you're a comic you think you're the
best period you know I know I'm a great
comic in any room I'm in I'm like I'm
the funniest dude in this room that's
how I feel that's how I try to perform
okay so all Comics feel this way so
there's been tension between them for a
long time about what happened but we'll
never really know the behind the scenes
and cat is giv his perspective about
what he thinks you know and the thing
too is like again let me just the the
interview on Club
Shay um is it's fascinating and I highly
recommend it's it's almost three hours
long and it's worth every hour just
listening to this guy yes there's some
there's some like really embellishing
and like really like you know some he's
really going in on certain things and
he's done this before but like when he
just talks about himself you know
Shannon sharp really got into it with
him and let him like tell his story you
know and Cat's a real fascinating
character and listen he's a great comic
like one of the best and it's just that
I think that he's gotten a you know
people have a weird perception of him
you know I think that especially
probably white people don't know who Cat
Williams is or maybe they they they have
a oh is that the ghetto comic or that
like there's a little bit of race you
know Prejudice involved in like why he
is or isn't what he is it's not a bad
thing per se it's just like you know
it's it's just kind of like if you've
never watch if you're like Middle
America white person and you've never
watched like you think all black comedy
is the same you know and I think that uh
de jam and Comic View and all these
things sort of perpetuated that that
this is how black Comics are and this is
what black comedy is but it's not it's
way more nuanced it's way more in-depth
than that you know there's a lot of
great some of the greatest Comics ever a
black you know and because of their
experiences and way they talk Chris Rock
Dave Chappelle they got they're also
great aors they speak a certain way and
you want to listen to what they have to
say you know but anyway my point is Cat
Williams is great you know you know so
there's all these people like talking
about him and you all these Comics are
mad at him and and and then there people
saying like oh he's just trying to be
relevant doing this nah man cat's
relevant because of who he is he's he's
chosen this path that he's on but when
he gets out there and puts something
down and he speaks it's worth watching
it's worth listening to
um you know what I mean it's crazy so
again you got to take a lot of the
things he says some of the things with a
little grain of salt you know it's like
you know he's he's a Storyteller too you
know it's like the part about Ricky
smileing when he was like oh it's in my
contract that he wear a dress no
freaking way okay like if you're Ricky
Smiley's people this would have came out
already you get what I'm saying like
there's no way you like what lawyer
would be like yes yeah yeah he got to
wear a dress or he can't be in the movie
this like that kind of stuff is like an
embellishing of the story that you're
just kind of like all right come on cat
why would you say that but you know he's
out there doing his thing so I'm not
condoning some of the things that he
said I'm just saying I understand this
personality and I'm saying it's very
fascinating personality so you know you
you take from it what you want when you
watch it you know you take from it what
you want uh but you know he the dude's
undeniable you know and I think
everybody and I guess you could say that
about me right now because I'm talking
about it is going to try to capitalize
off of what that is that's how Dynamic
of a personality that guy is that's how
powerful all this was you know he that
video has like something like 40 million
um let me see it's up to 41 million uh
views cuz you just look at this and
you're just like damn this dude is
something
else um you know what I mean like he's
made it like like this is for older
people too because
you know like most people don't even
want to watch something for this amount
of time three hours but yeah this is an
indepth interview into the personality
of a person to really like and then it's
okay to disagree with him but you can
still listen you know that's what we got
to get back to it's like a discourse
he's having so he may be saying some
things that are like outrageous but
you're just going to listen and you can
pick and choose some of these things I
like some of these things I don't but he
shouldn't be shut down right cuz that's
where this Society is going so I I'm
thankful for shanon Sharp and Club Shay
and Cat Williams for going on and making
people want to be like oh yeah oh let's
hear what this guy let's hear him out
let's hear him out agree or disagree but
let's hear him
out all right a lot to get to today guys
so I don't want to like stay on that I
might go into it in depth more as as the
time goes on about it okay so but we'll
see so um over the past weekend you had
the Golden Globes um you know shout out
to Joe Koy for um you know for hosting
the Golden Globes and uh you know it is
what it is man there's some people say
he did a he did a fine job and there's
people some of the jokes didn't hit and
whatever but you know what this is a
tough job man this is a tough job and
you have to look at it in context of
everything that's happened in the past
few years so they stopped the Golden
Globes because they felt like there was
some Prejudice going on there was from
like I don't want to say racism but
there was like some like you know uh
minorities weren't getting anything at
the Golden Globes the in the process of
making it and the voting and and
everything so they went away you know
and that's just a sign of what's
happening in society right now and then
you also had Ricky Jes as the as the
host for like two or three years and
hilar I love Ricky Jas and what he was
doing is hilarious as a comic I love it
because he was roasting people and he
was making points but you know what I'm
at my award show can I just get my award
show without getting clowned you know
I've talked about this before it'd be
like you in college and they call your
name they don't just call your name for
your diploma you know how they call your
names at a graduation they they would be
like it would be like if they went like
this uh and Eric Griffin
Eric be thinking he's studying but then
the guy clowns me he clowns me in front
of my friends and family as I'm getting
my diploma there's a certain part of
like Hollywood who are full of [__]
by the way you know full of like like
just dumb liberalism uh soft ass [__]
that's the that's a problem too by the
way I get that you know that you know
you know just in too much politics but
anyway they don't want that canz they
I'm dressed up my family's watching at
home can you just give me my award and
then at the same time too you got you
know all these people in Middle America
or all the people that are like you know
they they're conservative and they voted
for Trump and they vote you know they
vote Republican and then you got to
watch award shows and see these people
clowning your beliefs at an award show
and you're like hey man I just I like
that movie can I see if my favorite
movie won an award without you getting
on my politics so I think that that's a
lot of that has happened to the Golden
Globe ceremony in the past few years and
then you had Gerard carich last year I
love Gerard carmichel he's one of my
best friends okay I I love him but like
I called him and clowned him about what
he was doing you know I was like d why
you sitting down I was like only you
would sit down to do your monologue at
the Golden Globes but he was very like
hey he was commenting on what had
happened at the Golden Globes and why
they chose him he was like I'm here cuz
I'm black and you know and it was like
very much like yeah I think we all feel
that but you know he made it
uncomfortable right and as a comic
that's what we think you need to do and
what I'm saying but at the Golden Globes
they're like I think let's just make
this about the awards give out
Awards play music and just have an
escape from all this and I don't think
anybody wanted to host it I love Joe Koy
but like I don't understand why they
picked Joe Koy to to host this he's not
necessar in TV shows and movies he's not
necessarily A recognizable face uh you
know to the masses but this dude's a
multi-millionaire he sells out the Forum
he sells out stadiums all over the world
so people do know who he is but on a
scale for this I don't know if he was
the first choice but there was probably
a lot of people that were like nah I
don't want to do that I'm stepping away
from that or the you know and then he
was like I'll do it and he did a fine
job you know what I mean like the
ratings were up because he made it light
and fun and I and it was probably a
mandate from somebody and I don't know
this for sure but I'm sure I was like
hey can we just have fun uh this time
guys uh you know the writers they were
like hey should we clown this thing and
they were like ah how about we just make
some fun jokes and pass out Awards and
move and keep it moving you know and I
think Joe Koy was perfectly suited for
that he was super nervous and who would
who wouldn't be in that situation and I
think that if he did it again if he had
to do it again tomorrow I'm sure it
would be a whole lot better he'd be more
comfortable but hope this launches him
into you know being more of a public
figure because now everybody knows who
he is and it's crazy cuz there's people
all his millions of fans are like we've
been on the Joe Koy train where y'all
been so now so good for him for all that
but it was uh you know there are people
still talking about it but you know they
should just let it go cuz the dude did a
fine job you know what I mean with all
with all the all things
considered um you know what I mean so
it's like
just you know what what it is
uh
so yeah but Jim Gaff and I see people in
the chat talking about the Jim Gaffigan
joke you have to actually watch it
because Jim Gaffigan is just a he's a he
has a way of saying things that makes
whatever he's saying kind of it's it
it's easily palatable to your ears and
senses you know he just made a funny
joke because of what going on right now
with the Epstein which we're going to
get to next you know it's like yeah he
made this joke and everybody laughed
because of Jim Gaff and the way he said
it I mean he could have said it with
some like if Ricky Javas was saying the
same joke it would have hit completely
different right but it was Jim Gaffigan
so but you know this is what people do
they they they take they they look back
and try to overanalyze and make it more
than it was you know he was just having
a good he it was it was a funny joke in
the moment so uh you know if that if and
that's the way you want to do your
political quote unquote jokes the make a
point jokes you should make it in a way
where people can laugh and still go oh
yeah oh that guy got him you know what I
mean and we can still keep him moving
you know sometimes it could come off too
harsh and it's say what's that's not the
time and place this is a freaking award
show you know what I
mean
um so anyways um you know so and this
year we're not putting up with uh you
know no [__] this year from uh you
know people so you know because I
already see a a you know listen I don't
have to this is my channel you know what
I'm saying like this is my channel and
there are a million you know it's like
Airline you know when an airline pilot
says you have a lot of choices in
podcasts but thank you for choosing
Griffin with Griffin but I deserve the
right to to refuse any
customer okay I'm like the dut shop and
if you come into my dut shop and you
have your shirt off and no shoes and you
acting crazy I have the right to be like
you know what you can't have any of my
Donuts get the hell out of my shop
that's how it's going to be around these
parts sir so if you come in here with
some [__] about my friends about
other podcasts I do or or or just
talking smack about people that whatever
I don't have to have you here bye that's
how that's going to go so yeah anyways
let's get into another crazy thing that
happened in and you know as this Jeffrey
Epstein list came out a lot of people
talking about him making fun you know
freaking Stephen Hawking was on the list
you know Jeffrey Epstein man this
dude this dude
he's he probably got whatever that is
I'm talking about before like a cat
Williams like a you know like that sort
of Charis he obviously has some sort of
Charisma because you know he convinced a
lot of people that he was an important
person and he connected a lot of
important people and at the same time
had this terrible darkness in him where
he was doing some terrible things to
people right and he deserved to die you
know
so the thing about this thing though
about this list that has come out this
is not some what I don't like about it
is this isn't Some Like official list
like some investigators were like all
right here's all the people associated
with Jeffrey Epstein and this is how it
happened no it's it's it's actually
connected to the ca a particular case
and this is just stuff that was found in
Discovery but the way they're putting
this out it's like guilt by by
association so you could take that
however you want there's a part of all
of us that feels like if you went on
Jeffrey Epstein's plane and flew to the
island more than one
time there's a part of us that's like
how did you not know or see what was
going on it was it one plane did they
fly back and forth were the billionaires
and
whoever uh flying by themselves and then
they put the girl on the plane or were
the girls on the plane were they already
there that he fly them there separately
then they're waiting and then went and
got everybody like what are like just
get into the weeds and the Nuance of
everything that actually happened but we
you know we don't know they're not
they're not
releasing uh that you know so but
anyways so they put out this list and
what I don't like about it is is they go
like these are the people associated
with Jeffrey Epstein but it's like okay
well but what happened you know uh like
what were they doing so like for
instance a big name on the list that is
like so polarizing is Trump you know but
according to according to this thing and
according to uh you
know so testimony from the girl right is
that um that one time they diverted the
plane to New Jersey to visit a
businessman in 2001 won at one of his
casinos they to visit Trump Epstein knew
Trump you know Trump's a power player
he's make he's in casinos and making
money Epstein's on the you know he knows
Epstein as a power player that knows
prince Andrew and all these famous and
rich people so but then like you know so
he goes and then they ask the lady hey
did you massage Trump and she said I did
not all right and then they diverted
they couldn't even land in New York they
diverted the plane to New Jersey and
from these documents all right from
these documents it says well fste was
like oh cool since we in New York I want
to go check out my boy Trump let me go
visit Trump but when you put his name
out and listen I'm no Trump fan by the
way okay and that doesn't mean I'm a
Biden fan either let me just both these
[__] need to go away right but
anyways but like to put his name out
like this is shameful because it looks
as if you're trying to say
oh anybody that knew Epstein was a
pedophile anybody that knew Epstein was
having you know was doing terrible
things and it's like he put himself in a
position of power through some nefarious
means and through just being a Savvy
business guy and he also was a terrible
doing terrible things but not everyone
that came across him was guilty of
something and and and to put it out like
this all here's here's the list uhoh
look who's on the list and it's like
whoa whoa whoa can we get some more
facts about this list because you know
most people that just look at the
internet stuff y'all are stupid you know
y'all don't really care about facts
y'all don't care about Nuance y'all
don't care about having a discourse it's
just you see the words Epstein Trump oh
my God guess what that means and it's
like no no no let's get into the weeds
but it goes for all of these people that
are on the list you
know like Michael Jackson you know
Michael let let this guy's dead you know
what I mean like he's already his name's
already been dragged through the mud so
many times with stuff whether we don't
know what's true or what's not true but
even in this situation what they what
they came out with wait let me go to
that one what they came out with like uh
question did you ever meet anybody
famous when you with Jeffrey Epstein the
lady responds I met Michael Jackson oh
really and where was that at his house
in Palm Beach at jeffy's house in Palm
Beach he says okay did you massage him
no okay that's the extent of what
Michael Jackson's involvement was and
Jeff it like you know I I what I'm
saying is we just we don't know enough
from these documents to just be like
everyone associated with him is guilty
you know I just feel like if you're
going to put something out like this out
then you have someone like Bill Clinton
this dude's been on the he he on the
plane numerous times you know what I'm
saying uh public you know like what do
they say about Bill Clinton wait where's
the Bill Clinton one Bill Clinton um PR
accuser testified that Epstein told her
that Mr Clinton likes them young
referring to girls so that's from the
testimony from the girl this girl is
saying Epstein said that right uh
another woman who brought a testimony
against that said also mentions the
American political politician several
times you know again again like is there
someone admitting to doing something
with Clinton or one of these girls
coming out like how come they didn't ask
him
that you know like they asked about
Michael Jackson like hey did you massage
Michael Jackson where's the question did
you massage Bill
Clinton so Mr Clinton himself has said
he flew on ep's plane four times
including twice to Africa because they
work together on a humanitarian project
but those meetings took place before the
finance here came under investigation he
said and he had no knowledge of his
crimes I don't understand when they were
in this investigation and asking about
certain people why they didn't ask the
same
questions so I just that's why I'm
saying that I don't appreciate this
thing being put out like it's a mixtape
like it's some sort of like you know
album release uh W with like no like
in-depth facts because you know but by
the way if you're a person that's like
if you knew Epstein and you had
association with him for a a number of
time years or whatever I get you anybody
being like how did you not know you know
what I'm saying like you know so that's
also what's unfair that's why they took
so long to put this out that's why
people are still fighting that's why
Jimmy uh Kimmel was was so mad at Aaron
Rodgers for like hey D man don't just
say my name like that the association
with Epstein because that's what people
are going to do but that's what the
media does I find it hilarious that
Jimmy Kimmel who is like very much
liberal talk show host uh you know you
know who makes jokes about people's
Misfortune and and just saying things
Associates people with stuff and and and
and makes people makes people's lives
miserable and so that's what Aran Rogers
did made a joke whatever whether it was
true or not he said his thing and then
Jimmy Kimmel like [__] attacked he
was like don't you ever and I totally
get that but like where's that energy
for for other people in the world that
people just like put accusations out
about people with not a lot of
information and then where's the
followup where's the anger from people
being like hey hey can we get all the
facts but we don't seem to have all the
facts you know um yeah you know and
again like even like I see somebody
saying like you know when you say the
words like well Bill Clinton likes them
young like I mean that's a what is he
implying you know like Bill Clinton at
the time how old was he was he like he's
50 and his and the girls he was getting
with are 26 and up or you know even you
know like how you know if you're 50 and
the chick's 30 then okay you like them
young is that what that means but we
don't know there's no Nuance you know
but I just don't appreciate that they
didn't like ask everybody the same
questions ask the girl the same question
about all of these people when did you
meet them what was the nature of it did
you do anything with this person ask
those questions and then they just put
the things out but you know maybe more
things are going to come out but I'm not
surprised that dude was he was killed in
my opinion and this is why cuz I I'm not
saying everybody's innocent at all some
of these people did some bad stuff and
he knew about it he was probably taping
them he you know listen man this ain't
no new thing Epstein in 2005 was being
investigated 2005 that's almost 19 years
ago he was being investigated and then
somehow it just like nothing happened
right because he had stuff on powerful
people so there is some some some stuff
to be found out there is some like you
know they got to find this stuff out and
and and people should be brought to
Justice I guess right that's that's what
you know the point of this is but at the
same time it's like I don't know if if
it should be tried in the Press I don't
know the way this is being put out is
the fair way to the victims and to the
people whose names are just being
brought up you know it's unfair to Trump
it's unfair to to Clinton it's unfair to
all the people on that list you know
it's like uh you know it's unfair I
think it's unfair to this isn't
servicing justice as so much as it's
getting clicks and and getting people to
watch podcasts
right all right man I got so much to
talk about here we go um okay so let me
see what did I hit on I got the Joe Koy
I got cat Willams I got the Jeffrey
Epstein damn I wanted to get into the
NFL let's go let's do a brief NFL uh you
know this is exciting stuff man the NFL
playoffs are about to start and I mean
we you know the year started funky you
know we thought it was going to be like
the Jets we thought the Jets were going
to be one of the best teams Kansas City
was going to be one of the best teams
Buffalo you know all these teams and it
just didn't work out like that and it
did at the same time so you got the
Ravens number one seed best team in the
NFL in my opinion doing great they had
the best record in the league they got
Lamar Jackson all that drama he got paid
and it worked out cuz look bills tough
start to the year but now they they
started six and six and now they're 11
and they finished 11 and seven and they
got the number two seed in the East and
they won the NFC AFC East crazy like the
bills are the scariest team in my
opinion they're the scariest team if
they win the Super Bowl not going to be
shocked Chiefs they're having a down
year it would be a shocker to me if they
won the Super Bowl with that team they
going to have to retool but even with
all that number three in the AFC Texans
best story to me the best story it's the
best story rookie coach rookie
quarterback from a franchise that had
all that desan Watson stuff going on
they've completely turned it around
they've washed their history of that and
here they are and then you got the
Steelers I mean Mike Thomson is just one
of the greatest coaches ever never had a
losing season and now they're they
finished 10 and 10 and whatever it's
crazy that's that to me it's just
bananas that they finished how they
finished and then the Dolphins they've
only beaten one good team all year
they're they're decimated by injury and
if they win this game against the Chiefs
I'd be shocked and then my my sleeper
team for the AFC is the Browns I think
the Browns have a chance to actually go
to the Super Bowl and win it I wouldn't
want to play them they got the number
one defense Flaco's got experience he's
playing with like he's playing with
house money he's like man he's you know
he's like I already got a freaking uh uh
he's like I already got a freaking
contract I mean a Super Bowl so whatever
let's go he's like he's just playing
with nothing so then they
got the in NFC the ners best team all
year two second best team finishing but
they're a great team I think it's going
if if it's Niners Ravens in the
championship we're not going to be
shocked Cowboys is this the year the
Cowboys are going to do it I don't know
I don't trust Dak Prescott in the
playoffs so so he's got to prove it to
all of us and we'll see and this is a
great year to do that the Lions another
team that went from Rags to Riches they
had a great finished to last year and we
thought they would be this good and I
think they're just getting better and if
they don't do it this year they're going
to be the dangerous team next year I
think they'll be favored next year
Buccaneers give it up for Baker Mayfield
this freaking dude fourth team he was a
number one pick disasterous career so
far and look he finished with a better
record than Tom Brady's last year and
now they're in the playoff and they won
that garbage division again and then you
got the Packers shout out to Jordan love
finally he's doing it he's proven he is
a starting quarterback got the team to
the playoffs No rookie uh no rookie you
know person is he's not a rookie but
like first year starter Green Bay has
done this Brett Favre didn't get to the
playoffs Aaron Rogers didn't get to
playoffs in his first year then you got
the Rams my sleeper team in the NFC I
think the Rams I'm not going to be
shocked if the Rams make it to the Super
Bowl but you know and then the Eagles
debacle of a season get them out of here
garbanzo beans all right I don't want to
hear about the Eagles anymore it's just
a travesty how they are man so to the
Eagles man so enough with them um man
this a big episode we got so much we're
talking about all right so let's finish
off with something light I want to talk
about these two movies that I saw that I
want to talk about so I went to see the
movies you know Rachel was up for going
to see a movie so we went to see this
movie called poor things poor things you
know and it stars Emma Stone and shout
out to Emma Stone for winning the Golden
Globe for her performance it is this is
the weirdest movie I've seen in a long
time so the story of it is like the
incredible tale about the Fantastical
evolution of Bella Baxter a young woman
brought back to life by a brilliant
unorthodox scientist Dr Goodwin Baxter
okay that's a that's a soft that's a
soft way of saying what this movie is
about
man spoiler so it's the spoiler time I'm
not going to tell you everything that
happens but I'm just going to tell you a
little bit about what the movie is about
so um what's his name William defo plays
like Dr Frankenstein okay and he finds
Emma Stone's body in the the river okay
and she's dead but she has a baby she's
pregnant and she has a baby inside of
her and the baby's still alive so Dr
Frank Stein he decides to take the brain
of the baby and put it in the body of
the woman and reanimate her and so then
the movie goes from there and you're
sort of watching Emma Stone have an
evolution of being this like baby to
like a a a woman you know in this like
really weird Universe uh Mark Ruffalo is
in it and he is so funny I wish he was
not I think I don't know if he was
nominated or not but he was Hil
hilarious in this movie right again it's
a I I think that this movie is one of
those movies that artsy fartsy people
would sit around and talk about it and
being like Oh well her character
represents the such and such and such
and such you know I really feel like
it's one of those movies I don't know
offhand what I think the point of this
movie was and what it the point it was
trying to make on the grand scheme of
the universe but I do know that it does
make a point and I'm going to think
about it some more right because it is a
very strange movie two of my friends are
in it gerod Carmichael's in it and Ramy
yousef's in it um great and everybody's
great in the movie it's never boring but
it is weird as hell but let me just say
this though about the movie that I
thought was like something and I I know
there was a point to it but I don't know
what it is but I'll say this Emma Stone
she gets [__] in this movie like
pornographic like there's so much new
nudity from her in this like I didn't
think she was that kind of actress like
I I don't think I can recall any other
time in a movie where she's done this
much nudity and sex scenes
so even if you're not into the artsy
fartsy part of it and you're just some
you know if you're if you're in the
mstone just the movie to go watch and I
think you're going to be pleasantly
surprised by the by the movie itself but
damn she gets she gets dick down in this
movie
I mean I was like damn Amma
Stone you getting and then oh and by the
way and I'm not and she ain't getting di
down by like Ryan Gosling type dudes
either you know that's another thing you
have to see that's really strange to the
movie She but it's all part of the story
and I will say again I know that there's
a grander point being made in this movie
I just don't know what it is yet but I
for sure am going to like investigate
further because I would like to watch it
again and not for the the part that you
know like this this was just a real
fascinating movie uh but you know like I
say Worth to
watch
um it's worth to watch man uh so check
it out um okay so that's that movie and
then the last
movie uh that I saw that I wanted to
talk about is this movie
saltburn on
um on uh what do you call it it was on
Amazon
saltburn okay uh you gotta check this
out man the saltburn is like so it stars
uh Barry
kogan Jacob I don't know these other
guys whatever but just Barry you know
that's the guy Barry right there in the
white shirt this is the second most
bizarre movie I've watched in a while
and if you have Amazon Prime you can
watch it it's called saltburn so the the
the description says a student at Oxford
University finds himself drawn into a
world of charming and aristocratic
classmates who invites him to his
Eccentric Family sprawling estate for a
summer never to be
forgotten that is just honestly not what
the movie is about you know what I mean
if I'm being 100 that's not what the
movie is about man uh I'm not even going
to keep that up just so I can see uh you
know yeah man
[Music]
um Thomas dzel in the chat
brother everything that's all I'm gonna
say about that comment um anyways
saltburn is like a real strange movie
Very one very
homoerotic without being without being
gay at all right sort of you know
there's like a you when I first start a
movie and I was like the beginning and
what was happening I thought the movie I
thought there was oh is this like a gay
love story that's what you're going to
think the movie is about honestly you're
going to think that's what it's about
but I'm telling you right now it's just
a portion it's like it's a small part of
like an overall story that you have to
watch this movie to the end I will not
spoil this movie I'm not going to spoil
this movie but like some like there's
some real strange things and this dude
Barry kogan he's going to be the new
Joker this dude does an outstanding job
right you know and then and then like of
course the big thing everybody's talking
about is like there's this end scene
where he's dancing around this Mansion
butt ass naked and he butt ass
naked lot of dick in this just prepare
yourself for that lot of
dick in this part he he goes in you know
and and The Boy The Boy blessed not I'm
not going to lie boy boy boy packing
you know and he talks about it it was
all me but like it's such a weird movie
uh so many weird things happen you know
and it's it's very like a Talented Mr
Ripley type story if you like that movie
um but it like like some really strange
stuff like oh rigs in the chat that I
thank you for bringing that part up like
when I okay so when you think of like
it's
homoerotic sort of the things that
happen aren't what you think it's not
like you going to see somebody getting
blown or like you know it's not going to
be like some like like you know like
straight on man on man sex no no the
homoerotic part is like some bizarre ass
stuff I'm GNA give you one one spoiler
because the guy said it in the thing so
Barry the guy's character so there's
this other character and it's played by
uh what's the guy's name I think it's
played by uh his name is is Jacob that's
the guy Jacob El eler he's in uh he's
the he's in um um um what's it Euphoria
okay he's like the jock in Euphoria
who's who's you know what I mean but
anyways
so he's he's the the guy everybody likes
okay so he's like and he's taking a bath
all right and then the other guy Barry
he's his room their their their rooms
are connected at this estate that he's
staying at and and they have to share a
bathroom and he's peeking in on the dude
taking a bath okay and the guy's taking
a bath and and they they the guy's
masturbating right and so then the guy
leaves and then later Barry gets into
the bathtub all right and he's
like drinking the
water it's so it's and there's like so
many bizarre scenes like
that flashy beat said I'm a respectfully
pass
okay I mean listen I get it okay listen
I get it I'm just telling you it's not
about that but those scenes are in the
movie on purpose to make you
uncomfortable about everything that's
happening and who these people are but
when you see what happens in the end
you're going to be like oh what so
anyways that's that I give both poor
things and saltburn a woo
[Music]
Woos I forgot to count the Woos but we
did it but everybody look riffin with
Griffin um this
year uh we are really going to um I I'm
going to do more light-hearted stuff on
on the Wednesday free episodes and then
I'm gonna have like you know get into
the weeds of some things and really give
some like strong stronger opinions on
stuff in the uh the patreon episode
which will I'll be doing live on Mondays
on Twitch so if you start if you're
interested in me you know if you like
hearing my thoughts about stuff and you
just really want to get into it and we
and it could be some back and forth in
the chat that episode will be up on
patreon Mondays YouTubers twitch
subscribers so if you want to support
the show you could be any one of those
and I'm on Twitch every single day
anyway gaming so if you want to support
me and keep me going so because I got to
stay home a lot right now because of
this baby that's coming so you know it's
going to
be I I am I'm committed to making riffin
with Griffin better and you know we'll
see uh we'll see uh you know where it
goes from there since I see fishy in the
um in the in the uh in the thing because
you know what time it is now and we
still doing our oh I got to make a title
for that I got to make a rap recap title
that'll be kind of dope
right but we'll put it here
man oh yeah oh
yeah you know what time it is it's that
rap
recap and we back
2024 Eric Jean up in the
door got other podcast on the
[Music]
floor y'all know the
score uh I ain't no
[__] uh you know the
Lord let me check my
por woo NFL play off this
week uh I hope my team don't get
beat that FD
list everybody is the
[__] get more
Nuance then we can
[Applause]
dance whatever probably not supposed to
rap about the fste list but anyways guys
thanks for watching riffin with
Griffin we're back stronger better than
ever and I appreciate you guys being
here every single week so and if you
want to send me a beat Eric Eric
griffin.com thanks out for the fishy
beats thanks for all the people that
sent beats love all y'all and thanks for
watching and I'll see you on Monday and
I'll see you next
Wednesday